la lumière colorée fut et sera sur un
thème imposé la recherche de la lumière
du monde et avec une taille unique de
cadres 280 artistes des cinq continents
ont proposé trois cent cinquante
variations de vitraux des créateurs
majoritairement européens
mais le vitra et touche de plus en plus
de pays comme le japon ou la corée
traditionnellement les arts extrême
orientaux sont fascinés par la maîtrise
de la lumière à travers à travers les
différentes expressions et le vitrail
étant un art de la lumière par
excellence c'est vrai que là il ya une
sorte d'harmonie à une sorte de
filiation naturelle l'art millénaire du
vitrail s'est fondu dans le monde mais
aussi dans les techniques et matériaux
contemporains pour donner ses oeuvres
inattendu pour le public jusqu'à le plus
étonnant c'est de voir les capacités
d'une technique vieille de plusieurs
centaines de même presque un millier
d'années être capable de s'adapter pour
arriver jusqu'à l'impression numérique
comme on en voit sur certains sur
certains métaux ce qui distingue le
vitrail d'aujourd'hui du vitrail du
moulinage c'est justement là la nature
très très vaste des techniques qui sont
utilisés pour restituer l'image alors ça
peut être simplement de la peinture sur
verre comme autrefois mais ça peut être
de l'impression sur verre avec des
techniques numériques des techniques
photographiques
tel un cliché ou une case de bd le
vitrail a su s'affranchir des
représentations religieuses et se mêler
aux arts plastiques jouer avec la
lumière pour se montrer sous un jour
nouveau
ici vous avez les collages de 2k
beauchamp qui donne une surface qui
donne une épaisseur plus grande à la
verrière on est c'est vrai dans la
limite de l'exercice du vitrail face est
une nouveauté les artistes du vitrail
n'ont désormais plus qu'une seule limite
celle de montrer le monde sous toutes
ses couleurs et dans toute sa
transparence